now keep going citto Sensei used to
say that you should be able to cut and
go through a doorway the width of your
shoulders okay he say you should be go
through a doorway the width of your
shoulders so the question I'm going to
be asking you is can this man go through
a doorway the width of his
shoulders no why can't he his elbows are
too far out his elbows are too wide
they're too far out so you know just
most of you say oh that's me as well cuz
that will be so how is he going to get
these elbows in so he can go through
that door the width of his shoulders
it's going to be hard now he's going to
start fighting his own body trying to go
get them in get them elbows
in okay good you see you'll be a black
Bel in mons I'm sure cuz you see but we
all see it we don't realize what we see
but when I put the questions to you what
s ensei he was very good he was very
clever man he was a
Japanese that was with ensi for 24
unbroken years and because he couldn't
afford to pay for the lessons and he you
know sense he used to just teach the
rich then but CU he worked on the
railway nights he'd turn up and he'd be
at the
door um in the dojo and I essentially go
go and see what he
wants so he's he wants to join the
iido tell him how much it is then I
can't afford it B kept turning up day
after day so ENT she said look I tell
you
what they want somebody to throw about
you can never do any throwing but you
can be the one they throw so he so he
went for that
he said him for a
year since he made him do the attacking
side of what we call the first Kum
attachi only the attack inside but what
he said was because it was years before
he could actually do the throwing he
knew who was good at techniques and who
wasn't so he could just keep all this
information in his head the same as you
just saw that and now that'll never
leave you and you'll be in front of
their mirrors going oh they're too wide
I better pull them
in done it again pull them
in and that's how you build your
iodo so
here all right so I've learned how to
get
overcome C this feels blinking awkward
to fitting
it in if they're a little bit wide just
pull them in on the way down you know if
you make made a mistake pull them in on
the way
down I'm hoping that I'm encouraging you
to see how much Beauty there is in
getting it right um rather than just
pummeling away you
know I love this technique cuz I can
really get something out of it you won't
be able to when you're
73 all you needed where's my oxygen tank
so